[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to the
second episode of ask google cloud this
is a show where we solve humanity's
greatest mysteries like did the chicken
or the egg
come first oh wait hold on no
i'm actually being told that our poultry
experts aren't able to make it today so
we are just gonna stick with cloud
topics um i'm stephanie wong a google
cloud developer advocate and today i'm
joined by
dale markowitz an applied ai engineer
here at google and sarah robinson
a developer advocate focused on ai and
ml
and i'm both huge fans of you both
so dill sarah how are you doing thank
you so much for being here
thanks for having us steph i feel like
i've been seeing a lot of you lately
i'm omnipresent doing good over here
well i'm excited to have you both
today we'll be answering questions
submitted by you our amazing
google cloud youtube audience we're
always looking out for questions
about google cloud products so be sure
to leave any questions you may have in
the comments
of our videos using the hashtag
askgooglecloud
and if you have any other questions that
come up as you're watching today
then please go ahead and type them in
the live chat i think it's
probably somewhere over here and we'll
do our best to try to get to all of them
we'll be hosting ask google cloud
segments throughout the year so be sure
to subscribe to the channel to get
notified
every time a new episode goes out so
with that said let's go ahead and get
started with today's topic
which is ai and machine learning our
first question comes from verdict
who asks how do you get started with
aiml
with a non-technical background so dale
let's go ahead and throw this question
to you first man i get this question all
the time and my answer really changes
depending on what you're going for when
your background
is as a developer which is a technical
background
i always like to tell people you should
go you should go at machine learning by
trying to find a project that you
actually wanted to do anyway that uses
ml
and then just use the simplest tool for
the job so start with sort of high-level
tools maybe
speech-to-text api maybe a pre-built
image classification model and then once
you get the feel for how ml is useful
you'll be more motivated to like go
in and learn tensorflow and do the
nitty-gritty details um
but i'm sure i'm sure sarah you have you
have thoughts on this
yeah i think one of the cool things that
i've seen recently is there's a lot of
tools that are just making machine
learning more accessible
to people that may not have a technical
background so
things like automl which we'll get into
probably later on
um really help a lot with that there's
also a tool i adore called teachable
machines in fact i did uh
i've seen that on it's yeah even it's
like a way for you to train a model like
an audio or a vision model
and it's like i i had like um like a 10
year old kid
email me a model that he trained using
it so it's he's very smart but it was a
very user friendly tool
there's also a great resource called um
machine learning crash course which is
made available by google
it used to be just internal training
that was used at google but we made it
public a few years ago
i'm constantly going to the glossary on
that site just to look up
remind myself uh common machine learning
terms yeah that's awesome i mean if
if a 10 year old can do it although he
is super smart then i feel like that's
motivation
for us to get started and believe it or
not i was always okay at math and stats
and
and you know i wasn't classically
trained in technical skills i guess you
could say so
it's nice to know that you know i can do
machine learning by using all of these
resources
that you've just listed online um i
think now more than ever there's a
plethora of things that you can find
so well stephanie i don't think you
should hold other people to your bar
because it's pretty high but yeah but i
get what you're saying
oh thanks i mean we all have to start
somewhere right so
okay let's go ahead and move on to our
next question
who is from qrikzupa i think is how you
say it
who asks can you clarify what's the
difference between
vertex ai and your old ai platform this
is so confusing
okay i'm gonna admit that it's a bit i
was a bit confused at first too
but it's actually quite clear once
explained so sarah
will go to you for this one yeah sure so
i've been getting this question
a lot um since vertex ai was announced a
few weeks ago at google i o
um so basically how you can think of it
is that vertex ai includes everything
from
the ai platform that you know but it
also includes automl
and the best part is that it includes a
lot of new products for
ml ops ml operations so mlaps is
basically
the practice of productionizing your
models in a way that's scalable and
reproducible
um so the ml ops products that are part
of vertex ai
include pipelines feature store model
monitoring
maybe some others in there that i'm
forgetting um and then one of my
favorite parts about vertex ai is that
whether
you're training a model with automl or
you wrote your own custom model code and
something like tensorflow or pi torch
all of those models show up in the same
unified ui
and they can be deployed to the same
endpoints so it's a much more
streamlined experience
would definitely recommend that you use
vertex ai for all of your
new machine learning projects on google
cloud you can also migrate
your old models from automl or ai
platform to vertex ai
yeah i mean i've gotten the question a
lot too and
i like to tell people that you can think
about it like an evolution of ai
platform unified
so that like you said you have one
experience and interface for both automl
and creating custom models
but it's all shared infrastructure data
modeling ux
and api layer so that you can quickly
move from data science to production and
it's useful for ml novices for you know
without auto ml
uh but then you know as you become more
experienced you're able to manage
constraints and make your own
fine-grained decisions with vertex ai
so yeah this is exciting yeah you bring
up a good point about experience so
it's it's meant to be able to enable you
to use ml regardless of your
ml expertise so if you're new to machine
learning there's tools for you on vertex
ai that you can use
if you have more ml expertise and are
building your own custom models from
scratch
you can use vertex ai as well so it
works across the board
and just to rip off what you said sarah
i think we've been thinking about how
you build and deploy machine learning
models for a long time you know you need
gpus you need hardware
blah blah blah but the idea behind
vertex is well if you're actually going
to use ml in production
there are all sorts of other things you
probably would find useful that are not
necessarily
the ml part like keeping track of your
data sets and how they've changed
um and what what is your model doing
when it's making predictions keeping a
log of
of um how the data distribution is and
whether it's drifted so the idea with
vertex is
yeah you get the model building we get
all these other useful things that
integrate really nicely in one
spot and one api
well speaking of integrations in one
spot
uh this is a perfect segue because our
next question is from
chiro b who asks why would i use vertex
pipelines
when i can use vertex training and
prediction all parts of vertex
so sarah why don't you actually start by
answering that first
first let me start by describing what
vertex pipelines is um
so vertex pipelines essentially lets you
run end-to-end machine learning
workflows
on google cloud um using google cloud
infrastructure and you can write your
pipelines
using popular python libraries like cube
flow pipelines or tensorflow extended
um and so when you so a pipeline
consists of
steps or components um so you break each
ml task in your pipeline
down into a series of these steps um and
so one set might be for
importing your data set one step might
be for training then one step for
deploying your model
um so that's the purpose of vertex
pipelines and what you can do
is you can actually have a step that
would use vertex training
and vertex prediction so say you have a
model that you're training
you want to have one of your components
use the vertex ai
training service to train your model at
scale
and then maybe you want to have a step
that evaluates your model and
looks at a threshold so maybe you only
want to deploy your model if accuracy is
above say
95 um so you could have you can actually
add conditional logic to your pipeline
and then say check my model accuracy or
you can define whatever
metric you'd like see if it's above this
threshold if so deploy it to
vertex prediction but you can also use
vertex training and prediction on their
own you don't have to use it in a
pipeline
so what i probably recommend is as
you're getting started you know
prototyping developing your
machine learning models and workflows
start by just using
training and prediction standalone and
then when you're ready to scale that
and you've devised what all the steps
you want in your pipeline to be
then convert that into a pipeline and
run it on vertex pipelines
hopefully that clears things up i also
add and
so sorry stephanie i just also wanted to
add to what sarah said and tell me if
you agree
that i feel like with software
development there's often especially for
developing for the cloud there's often
this trade-off between
how easy something is to get working and
how
how easy it is to port between different
running environments
so if you were having a machine learning
pipeline running on premises in kubeflow
pipelines
you can move it from your local on-prem
environment to google cloud more easily
but it's probably more work to set up
pipelines than it is to just use
vertex's prediction service maybe
you get that running really fast but
then maybe that's harder to remove from
google cloud so there's sort of this
this compromise between portability and
ease of use
yeah i totally agree with that like if i
was building something on my own
maybe i would start by using training
and prediction but then let's say i
wanted to share it with you
dale and stephanie so that you could run
it on your own machine
it's going to start to get a little
complicated i'm going to need to make
sure that you're
you know using similar environments and
have dependencies set up so in that case
i might just want to create a pipeline
that that each of you could kick off and
then we could track
all the output from that pipeline across
different runs
yeah i love the option to have that
collaborative approach and what i love
about vertex pipelines is that it's
giving you ml
ops which we've we've touched on and
talked about here aka applying devops
strategies to ml systems so that you can
build and release code changes
monitor systems and reliability and it
and like you said it goes hand in hand
with training because you can reuse
a pipeline's workflow to train a new
model so i love how
you know it's all integrated into each
of these parts let's go ahead and move
on to the next question
which is from aravind s who asks
how do i use image data with natural
language processing and
we'll go to dale for that one hmm
interesting question there are a lot of
ways you can answer it depending on how
you interpret it
so one would be is is there text in the
image because that's a matter of maybe
using
ocr to extract the text and then you
just have a normal natural language
processing problem
but maybe you're actually asking about
like what are some cool machine learning
text
techniques to use images and text
together
i love this question because it's
something that people lots of people are
thinking about in the ml space
now normally we kind of like weirdly
siphon the way we think of ml problems
into
here's the set of video problems and
image problems and audio problems and
text problems
but in reality if you're trying to take
advantage of
data that's in the world or on the web a
lot of times what you have is a
multimodal data set you have images with
captions as one perfect example
um so is like for example learning how
to caption
images is one really neat combination of
these two modalities
one trend that i see that's exciting
today is the ability to find ways to
use machine learning to represent data
like images and text
so that what you learn from text
transfers to what you learn from
images for example if you if you have a
model that
looks at text and learns that um you
know
usually men are the ones that have
mustaches this is a very contrived
example
you learn something about the
relationship between facial hair and men
then maybe when you see images you can
transfer what you read about in text to
the images and vice versa so basically
humans learning from
from audio text and images and maybe
machine learning models can
now too okay so the next question is
from pascal
l who asks how can you use data from
google cloud storage or
bigquery to train models on google cloud
uh i love this question so let's go
ahead and go to sarah for this one
thanks stephanie so all of our services
across google cloud are
really well integrated which makes it
easy to import data from other places in
google cloud
when using it for training models in
vertex ai so when you're creating a new
data set in vertex ai you have a few
options for where you want to import
your data
you could either import a file locally
from your computer
you could provide a link to a file in
google cloud storage
or you could even provide the url of a
table in bigquery so for those of you
that don't know bigquery is our
enterprise data warehouse
so you can connect your bigquery data
set to your data set in vertex ai no
need to download the data and re-upload
it
uh vertex i will handle that integration
for you
and then one other thing i want to call
out is we have a tool called bigquery
machine learning
so what this lets you do is it lets you
take your structured data in bigquery
and use that to train custom machine
learning models and you don't have to
worry about writing that
underlying model code that's all handled
for you by bigquery ml you just choose
uh the type of model you want to use and
one other thing i'll mention is that
related to services being well
integrated if you're using a
vertex ai notebook our hosted jupyter
lab notebook solution
and all of your resources are in the
same project as that hosted notebook
instance
you don't have to worry about
authenticating that's all handled for
you
within notebook so let's say i want to
take my data set in bigquery
and download that into a pandas data
frame within my notebook
i can do that easily using uh the hosted
notebook solution
i think like as a lazy machine learning
engineer i
and surely many other people like
underestimate how much of a big
difference this makes
when like your data is kind of in the
same place as your notebooks
and your notebooks like are hosted on
the cloud and you don't have to be
constantly refreshing them it's really
really makes you more efficient whenever
it's all in the same spot
yeah there's something to be said about
a seamless experience without
you know context switching and the
authentication built in
it's integrated i think between google
cloud storage bigquery and vertex
you have options whether it's batch or
streaming data pulling it from google
cloud storage
or using the console or api to upload
from your computer or cloud storage and
and then make modifications and start
the training process
um so the next question is from lg good
who asks is it important to know
tensorflow and pie torch
so sarah can you answer this one yeah
sure so
the short answer i would say is that you
don't need to know both you can choose
whichever one
is best for the job there's definitely
no harm in learning both if you'd like
to
but both have really active communities
so if you need help with issues you're
running into
there's a good chance you'll be able to
find support and the good news is that
both
tensorflow and pi torch run on google
cloud vertex ai so if you
write models in either one you can train
and deploy those
on vertex ai easy enough so our next
question
is from chibi c who asks can i use
google cloud to train models and
generate predictions on
text documents dale i have to go to you
for this one
yeah actually we could both talk about
this because just the other week we both
talked about document ai on the tcp
podcast
so document ai is a tool for
everything machine learning and
documents whether something a picture a
paper document you take a photo of or a
scanned pdf
so it allows you to read the text off of
a page it allows you to understand what
text means within the context of a page
like maybe you have a table or you have
a form and you want to understand
this is the field birth date and this is
the value for within birth date
um so yeah the document ai tool set i
mean i don't know stephanie what what
did you think of that
yeah so once again we just talked about
this on the gcp podcast and what
fascinated me about document ai was that
under the hood these pre-trained models
that are built by google cloud
are using computer fission including ocr
and natural language processing
that creates these high value high
volume documents
and then meanwhile on the podcast we
also talked about you know
our knowledge graphs which validate and
enhance the fields in your documents
and you can train and create your own
custom document models and still have
human interaction with ai
to ensure accuracy when you need it so
pretty cool stuff
one of the things that this reminds me
of now you bring up the knowledge graph
is
i love like i i've completely i'm
a kindle person it's okay i don't need
paper books and one of the things that i
love about reading a book on a kindle is
if i don't know a word i click on it and
boom there's the definition it's like
you may be connected to the web
maybe i even get a translation all right
there in my book
this is a documentary enables a similar
thing where
maybe i'm looking at an invoice and
there's a business with an address
and i click something and because of the
integration between the data on the page
and the google knowledge graph i know
is this an active business and what type
of business this is by
linking it against web data right right
it's like not just
text anymore it's this window into more
metadata and information beyond that
which you know we can represent through
this knowledge graph so it's pretty
amazing stuff
our next question comes from mo b
who asks could you give tips on
operationalizing
ml models how would you go about it and
based on what
so dale how about we go to you
uh yeah sure i'm happy to answer this i
think like um
your biggest concern when you have a
model in production well there are a
couple first of all you want to make
sure
uh that the data that you're making
predictions against is same as
is the same as the data you trained your
model on this is like one of the biggest
places that people
have issues they train their model on
some sample data set and then when they
get predictions from the real world
they're out of sync
so when you're operationalizing your
model you want to a be able to have a
way to check for that to be able to
automatically over time as the world
changes
check for a drift between your trainings
data
and the real world data and probably
also a good way to deal with the fact
that the world changes
is to have a way of collecting the new
data as it comes in and you make
predictions your model
and then automatically retraining your
model and updating it with new data so
that's the first thing that comes to my
mind sarah i'm sure you have
a lot of thoughts on this yeah i would
add to that so everything you described
you can do that in vertex ai you can
automate this workflow using
vertex pipelines and one of the cool ml
app services that's available as part of
vertex ai is called model monitoring
so it lets you do exactly what you
described and detect
drift so if you're if the new
predictions that you're getting coming
in
are different from the data that you use
to train and evaluate your model
chances are you'll want to find an
automated way to get alerted about that
so you can set up alerts so that you'll
get notified
when a certain threshold is reached
based on
you know if you're looking for to
identify drift then you can kick off
model retraining um do whatever you want
within a pipeline
yeah and this all kind of speaks to this
other topic that we've recently had on
the podcast which was responsible ai
and to me ml ops is this major evolution
in ml practices because you can not only
reduce the amount of time it takes
but you can reliably go from data
ingestion to deploying model in
production
and like you said monitor and understand
your ml system
uh it's reliable it's efficient and you
get that explainability that
transparency
so that you can have these healthier
more representative
practices and models so yeah one thing i
actually forgot to mention
is one of the great things on vertex ai
is feature attributions
which are available for different model
types so for example if you train a
tabular model
in vertex ai using automl you can get
feature attributions which basically
show you
which features influence your model
prediction the most and what what's
signaling that prediction so it really
lets you
you know look under the hood and have a
better understanding of how your model
is
performing yeah and you were able to
leverage some of this
for some of your past projects like the
the cooking one right
yeah definitely that was a fun one yeah
sarah
this is sarah's project originally but
she invented new recipes using machine
learning and then we kind of
riffed on it together and yeah you wanna
tell us about it
yeah definitely um and you should all
check out the video that dale and i did
on this
basically what i did is i've been baking
a ton during um
the past year and started to notice that
baking recipes in particular
follow a lot of distinct patterns so
there's a specific ratio of like flour
to fat to sugar
that makes a cookie distinct from a cake
so i wanted to see if i could train a
machine learning model to
start out i trained a model to predict
what different recipes were
starting with just three labels bread
cake and cookie
and then i wanted to see if i could use
this model
tweak the features the inputs play
around to see if i could invent a new
recipe so
the first one i created was this hybrid
cake cookie that i called it cakey it
was pretty delicious
we attempted in the video um and we also
make a new one
it was fun yeah you have to check that
out and i think you also
partnered with mars and did some things
with confectionary and
you made some recipes with that too so
you've done a lot in this space
yes big fan of baking and i'm out maybe
if anyone has a
baking machine learning expert i think
in the world
yeah it's such a fun hybrid yeah the
mars project was really cool too
basically
flipped that the model that that dale
and i described in the video
flipped that so instead of providing
ingredient amounts as input you provide
what you want to make so i would say you
know i want a 50
cake 50 cookie um and it would tell you
the amount of certain
base ingredients that you need to make
that so there's a blog post on it
um we can provide a link i might need a
spin-off show for you
i'm up for it all right so our next
question is from
idrl indian drone racing who asks
how can we use less images to train a
model so
dale can you help us out with this one
yeah i think the question is how can we
use less
data to train a model in general and
also like do we even need to train a
model this is what i'm always thinking
about because
if you follow at all like the projects
that i build using machine learning i'm
always trying to like avoid collecting
data this is the slowest part of the
project this is the most error-prone
part of the project
um it prevents you from prototyping
quickly so i'm always wondering like how
how do you get the most animals without
finding data so the
answer that everybody usually thinks of
is something called transfer learning to
understand how transfer learning works
you kind of have to
understand that the way that machine
learning works in general is not that
just that you're learning from data to
understand how to do a task like
identify dog breeds right that a machine
learning model when it looks at tons of
images not only is it learning to
identify dog breeds it's also
forming some understanding of the world
in general
it's understanding that animals have
ears and two eyes and usually a nose in
between so
in addition to trying to learn what your
task is it's also representing the world
this allows you to take a model an image
model for example that was trained for
something completely unrelated to
classifying dog breeds
maybe it's used to classify all sorts of
objects
and then you bring your own data with
your own custom task and you tweak and
you tune that model to do what you want
so you take the model that understands
the world then you say okay but now
find a way to do my specific task so
this is transfer learning it's been used
you know for a couple of years now most
image models will build on top of
another image model
but we're seeing this even go farther
now um like for example there's there's
sort of a trendy topic called
one shot learning where the idea is i
want to get a model to do my own custom
task
but i'm only going to provide like a
couple of examples i'm not going to
provide a whole training data set i'm
going to depend on the model being good
enough to be able to generalize
and if you look at models like gpt3 this
is a text model a really
really good multipurpose text model you
can get this
model that was trained once on one data
set to
write code write poetry do translation
be a chat bot
so we're moving forward towards this
trends in machine learning where can you
build a large model that's
really good that's so good in fact that
you can use it for multiple tasks
without finding trading data
that is my hope for where we get to to
answer the question of how do you avoid
collecting so much image data yeah yeah
it's really exciting because
i feel like it's all about making this
more efficient and the upfront work
less on the people who are doing it and
if i understand correctly so transfer
learning means reusing
a pre-trained model on a new problem
that you're trying to solve so like for
image classification or nlp like this is
a starting point for you
to help develop a neural network model
on image or these types of problems
because
typically there's like a lot of compute
and time resources required right
yeah you could kind of think of it as
imagine you need a you need a data
scientist to write sql
um but you all you have is like a
software engineer right but you can
there's a lot of skills that transfer
between writing sql and writing python
code so like it's better
to start with a software engineer
they're going to get the basic concepts
and then you can like
you can train them with less time to to
do the other task
right well there's a lot happening in
the space so i'm sure it's going to get
easier and easier as time goes on
so the next question is from taha who
asks
is tensorflow.js the way to go if you
want to do
real-time computer vision on the browser
i really wish i could do that with
opencv
so dale let's start with you yeah sure i
guess you're asking me because uh
we've talked about a recent project i'm
working on with tensorflow.js
what i love about tensorflow.js and also
the tools built on top of it
is that it's just machine learning part
of aside
it's just has a lot of nice utilities
for collecting sensory data from the
browser whether it's from the camera
or for a microphone um it has like um
library structures to just hook into
that stream really quickly and so it
just makes any sort of um like you know
real-time sensory based
project much easier to build i don't
know have you have you guys played with
this at all
i haven't played with tensorflow.js yet
but i have been meeting too
i'm excited about your your new project
on it
yeah building a pet cam so i'm excited
they actually talked about this in io
pretty extensively when they are
covering ai so
seems like it's uh something that is to
be focused on
the next question is from diego en who
asks
how do i use ai solutions in a small
business
with a low budget so sarah can you help
with this one
yeah definitely this is a great question
um so the first thing i'll mention and
this is available across a lot of
different google cloud services not just
limited to ai and ml
is to take advantage of auto scaling so
for example when you're
deploying a model uh when you're
configuring the machine type and the
settings you can set that to auto scale
so that you'll only be charged
um when you're getting prediction
requests on your model and then if
it's not active it'll scale all the way
back down to zero
but i will also mention that that automl
which we've talked about a bit
is pretty cost effective and a great way
to start prototyping and developing
models that could eventually become your
production models
so for example if you want to train an
automl tables model
an hour of training which i find usually
gets me pretty good accuracy
costs 20 and for video
text and vision it's actually only three
dollars per
hour of training just found this out
today super excited about that
um yeah pretty awesome so another thing
to think about is like your time is also
valuable so if you're gonna be spending
time like spinning up a lot of this
infrastructure
um it might it might be a better use of
your time to just
use the cloud take advantage of managed
services to do that
yeah right 100 agree with what you just
said sarah
like zooming back from the skus on
specific costs of products and compute
time or whatever like the most expensive
thing that you could possibly spend
money on is probably buying like a set
of phds or data scientists right totally
so the way you can really save money is
especially when you're starting off when
you're building an app totally from
scratch
use the pricier tool if it's like way
easier to use
build out the prototype and then bring
in the experts once the proof of concept
works
right because chances are you want to
focus on your machine learning skills
and
improving and making sure your data
looks good
and using managed services really let
you focus on like the core of your
machine learning tasks rather than
spinning up all that compute
yeah i totally agree i can't overstate
the importance of
you know getting up and running quickly
and then utilizing managed services and
moving towards that progression of
hiring the right people
and you know like we said earlier vertex
ai is that platform that you can
continue to develop and progress
as your business gains more resources so
unfortunately that's actually all the
time that we have for today
so sale sarah and dale i want to thank
you so much for spending time with us
uh before we wrap up completely
dale do you have anything that you want
to leave with the audience
i just really really want to know what
people are working on so
if you have a machine learning project
please tell me about it tell me about it
on twitter
if you disagree with anything i said
pick a fight with me i just i want to
know what you're thinking
so thanks for thanks for having me steph
all right she said it she's willing to
take a fight with you um
so sarah how about you yeah i would echo
everything dale said and also i want to
add i'm working on building out some ml
tutorials and i'd love to hear
what kinds of tutorials you want to see
so please drop a note in the comments
and let me know what you're looking for
yeah and i think
you know we'll try to include some links
in the description
um today and after today and we're going
to be responding to your questions so
thank you everyone for joining this
episode of
ask google cloud live chat we hope that
your questions got answered and we're
going to be back
with more of these live chats throughout
the year we'll be featuring your
questions from
youtube instagram twitter so send in
your questions
using the hashtag askgooglecloud and
comment below if you have a question
that we didn't get to today
i want to thank you all for watching and
we'll see you all next time
bye
[Music]